في موضوع اخر قال للمركز الاورو متوسط
الزلازل ان زلزالا بقوته 6 درجات وثمانيه
اعشار الدرجه على مقياس رختر ضرب منطقه
هندوكوش شرقيه افغانستان وجزء من باكستان
حول هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من مدينه مزار
شريف مراسل الجزيره ناصر شديد اذا قوه
الزلزال سته درجات وثمانيه اعشار على
مقياس رختر ما الذي يصلكم من معلومات عن
اوضاع تلك المنطقه التي ضربها الزلزال
ناصر
حتى هذا الوقت لا يوجد معلومات عن وجود
ضحايا او سقوط ضحايا لكن الزلزال شعرت به
جميع الولايات الافغانيه شمالا شرقا جنوبا
كل هذه المناطق صحيح انها كانت في شمال
افغانستان في ولايه بدخشان عند جبال
هوندوكوش لكن في كل مناطق افغانستان شعروا
في هذا الزلزال الذي هم متعودون على وجود
هكذا زلازل لكن بهذه القوه بهذه الدرجه لم
يعني يتوقعوها او لم تحصل قبل ذلك بهذا
الشكل خاصه في العاصمه الافغانيه كابول
ايضا شعروا بها بشكل كبير نحن هنا في مزار
شريف كنا في الفندق مجرد ان حصل الزلزال
نزلنا الى الى الشارع وجدنا عدد كبير من
المواطنين الان خف المشهد بعد ان هدا
الوضع تقريبا استمر الزلزال
55 ثانيه وكان قويا
ايضا يعني ايضا بالنسبه
للشعب الافغاني كما قلنا متعود على
الزلازل لكن هذا الزلزال كان شديدا وحتى
هذا الوقت لا يوجد اي معلومات عن وجود
ضحايا او مصابين لكن الوقت مبكر وكل ما
يتمنوه حسب مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي ان
تكون هذا الزلزال مركزه الجبال ولا يكون
هناك اي اضرار عند المدنيين لان الوضع
اصلا في افغانستان هش كثيرا فهذا الامر
لربما سيزيد من يعني تبعات المشاكل
الانسانيه هنا في افغانستان قبل نحو تسعه
اشهر كان هناك زلزال في جنوب شرق
افغانستان واحدث اعداد كبيره من القتلى
والجرحى خاصه في مناطق جبليه في اوقات
الشتاء فلذلك كان هناك ضحايا
تصل اعدادهم الى 400 قتيل في ذاك الوقت
نعم شكرا جزيلا لك من مدينه مزار شريف
مراسل الجزيره ناصر الشديد